the movie opens by showing us the
decrepit hand of mary shaw lighting a
candle and this could be seen as a
foreshadowing of what would eventually
happen to the theater in the movie's
climax but it may have also been chosen
as sort of a director's trademark for
james juan
after their breakout success with saw
juan and screenwriter lewinell teamed up
again to make dead silence which was
released in 2007 and contained many
recognizable elements that established
juan as an auteur the opening shot of
saw contained a small blue light
floating in the water so dead silence's
first shot has its colors altered so
that the flame's light also appears to
be blue
one of the first things we see are her
blueprints for the perfect doll which
are also pretty similar in style to the
designs made by the antagonist of
juan's first movie dead silence would
not only bring back more trademarks
established in his previous film but
would also set up conventions that
wouldn't be expanded upon until
years later in his career for this and
many more things you missed make sure
you stick around
to the end of this video
am i becoming like the doll movie guy
it's really not on purpose it just kind
of
keeps happening anyway the opening title
sequence shows mary shaw flipping
through a photo album it's difficult to
see the details but if you do pay
attention to them it sets up a secret
that would later be unveiled
when the mystery is all but solved we
find out that mary shaw's spirit is
going after the families that killed her
and dismembered her tongue in 1941
so essentially the curse is tied to your
lineage and that's why we see her
documenting each family tree
from the birth of a new son in the ashen
family to the introduction of aunts and
uncles the tracking of new wives and
daughters cousins with creepy faces
and more further on in this booklet we
see her design sketches and blueprints
jotted down about the perfect design and
making the perfect doll we see the doll
parts like legs and eye triggers which
we don't realize are part of the
construction of a human doll unless you
really look closely at the proportions
we see more of this book when jaime
discovers it later on while exploring
the theater where there are more
diagrams that seem to be plans for the
human version of the doll as well as
pages about surgery and human anatomy
i'd also like to comment on the music
the soundtrack was done by charlie
klauser who also worked with juan on the
song movies and the main theme sounds
like a children's wind-up music box
which fits nicely with the whole theme
of dolls and kids being
turned into ventriloquist dummies and
stuff the main character is jaime ashen
and he seems to have a passion for
bicycles judging by the decorations in
his apartment
he has a vintage bicycle poster in the
kitchen the cycles gladiator poster
which i found out is actually a type of
wine not a bicycle brand but still
features a bicycle on the label and of
course
actual bicycles i think that the
reasoning behind these choices has less
to do with the actual bicycles and more
to do with the idea of mary shaw's curse
being generational
each subsequent generation of the ashen
family represents a new life cycle a new
victim for mary shaw to circle around to
that's why the first victim of the movie
appears to be his wife but turns out to
actually be the boy she was carrying
when the package containing the
ventriloquist all arrives at their door
jaime's wife lisa makes an interesting
promise to the
if you get doll to scream i'll make sure
you get seven minutes in heaven with my
old bar
reel it's an interesting choice of words
because the legend of mary shaw warns
that the victims should not scream
in fact the movie ends when jaime
actually does screen and he pays the
price for it
another potential attempt at
foreshadowing can be seen on jaime's
fridge and i say potentially because i
can't confidently translate the meaning
behind all of these fridge magnet
letters but one thing that does stand
out to me is the word lake the theater
where mary shaw's curse began which is
also the location of the climax of the
movie is located on the island in lost
lake but perhaps the biggest easter egg
i found in jaime's apartment
was this which at first appeared to be
just a painting but upon closer
inspection i realized was actually a
jigsaw puzzle
this is a clear connection to saw where
the villain would cut jigsaw pieces out
of his victims bodies
when jaime comes home from picking up
takeout he finds his wife's dead body
under a sheet which is great for me
because i can show some of the scene and
again
great for me because i can point out
another director's trademark covering a
victim in a sheets to create suspense
was also a tactic that juan used in song
where sing and tap discovered jeff
reidenhour there's also another cloth
pull scene later in dead silence where
it looks like the same cloth is even
used
this could also explain why james wan
became friends with light's out director
david sandberg
in the following scene we meet the man
who would be investigating lisa's murder
we can tell he's a cop not by the fact
that he's in a police station but
because he's eating a donut and we all
know that cops
cannot resist donuts just refill this
with jelly will ya
thanks you're an angel when jamie gets
back into his hometown ravens fair he
drives by a sign describing it as
a quiet place which coincidentally would
be the title of an excellent horror
movie 11 years later where the
characters were also at risk of being
killed if they screamed but what i
actually want to point out was this logo
at the very top of the sign
it's very similar to a logo seen later
on the grave markers of mary shaw and
her many puppets this could suggest that
she has a greater influence on the town
than previously disclosed the town is
now run down and falling apart like the
real life equivalent of screenrat's
reputation we see mannequins in the shop
window and we would later find more
mannequins at the theater
at this point in his career i think it's
safe to call this another director's
trademark you may remember from saw that
jigsaw's workshop is hidden in a
mannequin factory
it's an old listing used to be a
mannequin factory what can i say and the
dude loves mannequins but i think
there's actually something deeper going
on here
let's take a closer look at some of the
recurring elements in his films
mannequins dolls and we later see mary
shaw take over a ventriloquist clown
there's one thing that all of these
elements have in common they're all
prompters for a phenomenon known as the
uncanny valley effect which is when
something has a human likeness
but is not human or at least has
something non-human about its appearance
causing our brains to think that
something is wrong which is why a lot of
people find clowns dolls or even the
original trailer for sonic to be kind of
creepy but i would say that's something
that juan finds fascinating because
we've seen examples of it come up time
and time again in his word i mean the
dude's instagram handle is creepy puppet
jaime's first stop was to his childhood
home to visit his father but the
surprise he would find there holds major
clues about the movie's twists
[Music]
when jamie returns home the door is
answered by ella
oh oh no please please don't tell me
that's your mom
dude well i guess i'm your stepmother
yeah she's pretty young i mean i guess
she's not technically young because of
the whole part where we find out that
she's actually mary shaw there may be a
clue in there in that she has this
vibrant
eye color which is shared by the creepy
version of mary shaw and all of her
dolls the next part i legitimately don't
get like i don't understand it let me
roll the clip
isn't the whole twist that the father
has been dead the whole time and she's
controlling him like a life-size
ventriloquist doll so
who's saying that i mean the only thing
that i can think of is that she can
actually give the dolls a voice of their
own because we do see a similar effect
in the theater flashback where the
audience reacts as if billy's voice is
actually coming from the crowd
you won't find me mother
i guess the idea behind mary shaw's
perfect doll is that she taxidermy the
father and converted him into a
ventriloquist doll i think the idea is
teased at when jaime goes to the funeral
parlor and sees marion walker playing
with a stuffed crow another example of
the use of taxidermy but can we just
talk about how hilarious this lamp at
jaime's motel is though it's just like a
fish spitting out the
lamp that's my kind of humor also at the
motel scary faces behind
a window curtain director's trademark
the next day is lisa's funeral and there
are a couple of tributes hidden in the
cemetery set the first one is this
tombstone with the name
john musica john musica is the name of
an ontario-based locations manager but
he doesn't appear to have been involved
with dead silence as far as i can tell
so i wonder if this is actually a
graveyard set that has been used in
another production before and this
headstone was just kind of left over
the alternative is that he just wasn't
credited and if you've seen my last
video
you know that's never good another grave
marker has the name gregory which was
likely a tribute to the late producer
greg hoffman who is always credited
posthumously by his friends orrin kools
and mark berg jaime learns the name of
the ventriloquist doll billy
which is the name of the puppet used to
deliver messages to the victims and saw
the saw version of billy would also make
a little cameo later in this movie
we'll get there a little bit later on
though the name of the theater that mary
used to perform at is called the guinea
theater that's a french name that is
correct dorell guinol
translates to puppet and it may have
been more specifically named after a
french theater the grand guignol which
was known for the horror productions
that it put on in the early 1900s seems
appropriate given all the horrific
moments in this movie like an old woman
asking to be made into a doll after her
death and
this part where her ghost can only be
seen passing by in the mirror but after
exploring the theater and its history
and trying to rebury billy himself jaime
is unable to find the answers he's
looking for about the connection between
his great-uncle michael ashen
and the curse of the ventriloquist mary
shaw he returns home again to confront
his father
most of mr ashen's lines are delivered
in close-ups so that we as the audience
don't see ella's lips moving
as he's speaking however in this shot we
do get a glimpse of it but it's brief
enough that
most probably wouldn't notice we also
see it happen again in wide shot while
our eyes are drawn to the motion of
jaime leaving the room
similarly when jaime receives the phone
call from henry walker the funeral home
director who was killed by mary shaw not
long before
ella is conveniently not in the shot
until henry's voice stops so again we
can't see her lips moving although
detective lipton does try to stop him
jaime storms off to go meet henry at the
theater
actual footage of me being nominated as
a designated driver
once they do arrive at the theater
though the detective finally starts to
believe that the ghost stories might be
true when he hears the voice of henry
coming from seemingly nowhere
yes
you said i told you so i'll shoot you
you know officer that sounds a little
bit like brutality
jaime disappears into a secret area
behind the wall leading them to discover
that all the dolls from the cemetery
have somehow been relocated here
one of them looks a lot like an early
version of the annabelle doll that would
debut in james wan's 2013 film the
conjuring obviously i don't think he
predicted the future and knew he would
be making the conjuring because the
original plan for that movie was to use
the raggedy and doll that looks like
this but once it was decided that they'd
be making a scarier-looking doll for the
film i wouldn't be surprised if he went
back
and said okay why don't we use something
like this the first doll that mary
possesses in the scene as i mentioned
earlier is the clown puppet and it has a
spiral on its forehead which
is yet another connection to saw where
there are several spiral patterns most
notably on the cheeks of billy the
puppets this is also the scene where
billy makes his cameo he can be seen
lying on the ground in the dark whenever
they cut back to the wide shot
saw also featured some spiraling camera
movements and i think we can count this
as another example of james wan being an
auteur i noticed one such movement back
at the house not to mention the fact
that they have a spiral staircase
detective lipton does what probably
anyone would do in this scenario
[Applause]
but unfortunately for lipton he can't
stop himself from screaming
and he gets the old tongue ectomy
treatment jaime on the other hand is
able to catch himself before screaming
in mid-air might i add and he burns the
place down and goes home
one final time to take care of the last
doll when he gets there there's one more
in director's trademark the recap
montage
let's roll it
you didn't kill it
jamie glad to have you home
now who's the dummy
there's a good amount of lore in this
movie that i've yet to cover so be sure
to join me next week as i analyze the
history of mary shaw
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring that death
bell for notifications and i'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survived
[Music]
[Applause]